[Music]
I'm welcome to let's talk
I'm sherrod Curtin this is the show that
brings you the most important
conversations the day yesterday we
talked about education we talked about
STEM education science technology
engineering and math and we had a panel
discussion and today we're gonna
continue that but looking at just one of
those elements math mathematics if you
wanna be pedantic about it now the
person I have with me is a very
interesting because he's a teacher at J
Buc technology High School in Sydney
he's a YouTube sensation with hundreds
of thousands of subscribers to his
YouTube channel and last year he won
Australia's local hero award at the
Australian of the Year awards and who am
I talking about I don't want any woo and
he would thank you so much for joining
me this evening okay I know you've had a
very busy day speaking to lots of people
engaging with a lots of Malaysians but
tell us about that a bit of you since we
let's get to know you a little I know
your parents moved from Malaysia to
Australia sometime in the 80s sorry in
the 70s you were born in the 80s right
you mr. Trotta Lee Young something so
successful in fact March last year you
were named as a top 10 finalist of the
global teacher prize now that's the
reason you're on the show because you
now focus on education we know that
teachers extraordinary important now
tell us and TEDx I believe did you did a
talk on spiel on TEDx and you explain
something but people who hadn't see that
tell us about your journey but journey
that took you from the love of English
literature and history into math I'm
definitely not what you would expect as
a stereotypical mathematics teacher
even though perhaps on paper you know by
my appearance you might jump to a quick
conclusion but when I was in high school
it was the humanities that I always
loved the most I was an avid reader I
chalk that down partly to the fact that
I'm the youngest of three children my
brother and sister quite close in age
and then after a while there was me and
I brought
sister could you an afterthought ah
maybe yeah yeah that's that's the way I
viewed myself to be honest I my brother
and sister could always do very similar
things they could go and watch the same
movies they could engage in the same
sports and I was always too small too
uncoordinated and so in many ways I
turned to books as something which I
could enjoy and I could do on my own and
so history and English in subjects like
that which really leaned towards those
reading skills that's where I was most
naturally at home at least to begin with
okay so this is a really interesting
setup because then there's this move
into into mathematics in the field
because you wanted to be a teacher and
you wanted to be a teacher of English
literature and and history now that
framework will before we get to the
maths issue being someone who loves
books and you know stories and such did
that shape the way that you are because
you clearly become a communicator and
that is I think one of the chief
characteristics of who you are as a
person today how is that because it
seems to me we often talk about STEM
education in STEM subjects a ton of
apart from history which now devalued
and English and literature that's also
devalued how do you see that and I do
think it's a real shame that
unfortunately there's become a bit of a
false dichotomy between these different
styles of learning which were always
intended to be complimentary and to
touch on different parts of human
knowledge and human understanding but as
a consequence of schools being very you
know structured and we have specialists
in this subject in that subject
I think we've somewhat lost touch with
each other I mean I'll give you a
classic example in my school in the
staff room that I sit in we have all the
mathematics teachers gathered in one
spot and then beside them in a separate
area we have the Creative and Performing
Arts teachers we have the musicians the
dancers the artists and this section
being separate from mathematics to me is
heartbreaking because there is so much
mathematics in music when we think about
rhythm and melody and harmony all of
that is mathematical and I could
continue that list the sciences are rich
with mathematics and when we think about
history and the understanding of
statistics and ways tree is going today
it can
makes one whenever you dig into
something you can find mathematics in
there so I think that that that's a
distraction to think of them as separate
things it's really important for us to
recover that unity in fact okay you've
been quite public about how bad you were
at that at an early age right in fact
you you went so far as to say maths was
not really my thing but stories
characters narratives you said those are
things that where you feel most at home
so how did it happen
that you found this in math there was a
very secure discern a that I took to get
to mathematics and as you mentioned
before it really came through my love or
the the love that I grew of education
and learning and teaching I had a great
opportunity at high school to engage in
lots of extracurricular activities so I
was things like an Army Cadet I was what
we call a peer support leader in
Australia so as younger students come
into the school I would be one of the
teachers the students would mentor them
and look after them help them adjust to
the new school environment and by doing
things like that I realized that I loved
interacting with younger children I
loved helping them learn skills that
they thought were impossible for them to
reach otherwise as an Army Cadet would
do simple things like how to pitch a
tent or how to navigate your way through
the mountainside things that are very
intimidating for young children but with
the right support and guidance they can
learn these skills that's what set me on
the path to becoming a teacher and when
I got to university I realized that
there was a huge need in Hulme a somatic
sort Ajay understand one that's not that
dissimilar to here in Malaysia and
because my love of teaching came from
making an impact on the lives of young
people
it wasn't my particular love for a
discipline over another one I realized
if there's a need here if there's a
shortage if there's somewhere I can
supply a useful service then mathematics
is the place to go you know if you make
a joke about the stereotype of the Asian
Australian or somebody of Asian descent
try to get getting into math but getting
into teaching would be something I think
here well there are a lot of people who
don't think teaching is a career path to
success they often think of teaching is
lowly pay with long hours
and they're repetitive what would be
your plug for the teaching profession I
mean why should somebody who's bright
and articulate and full of passion like
yourself or anyone get into teaching
there are so many ways that I could
justify the whole idea of teaching but I
would highlight probably three things
I'm leaning very much on not just my own
experience but the researcher of people
like Dan pink Dan Pink's done a lot of
psychological research into the area of
motivation what is it that keeps people
motivated long term in you know whatever
kind of pursuit or hobbies or profession
that they go into and he talks in
particular about three qualities that I
find really fascinating he talks about
autonomy mastery and purpose and these
are things which all human beings know
what a matter what field they go into no
matter what hobbies they pursue we want
to have some sense of control we want to
have some flexibility in the ability to
choose our own direction some autonomy
over how we do things which we want to
gain a sense of mastery as well there's
there are a few things as satisfying as
developing and increasing in our skill
and saying yes this is something I have
a skill for I have expertise in this
area and then of course we want what we
do to count we wanted to have a long
term impact we want there to be a
purpose for which we can say at the end
of our lives yes that was that was
worthwhile okay I get that about
teachers teachers can be of tremendous
consequence for the lives of young
people and we all remember our favorite
teachers and so on and so forth well
Tana B is not something I would
associate with the teaching profession
partly because of the curriculum it
seems that many teachers are tied to
that curriculum especially in countries
like ours where you know what the
education system is fairly authoritarian
as the government had been for many
years right and now we see a real
attempt to change it why would you
associate teaching with autonomy I knew
that question was coming she writes
right into it
you're right and to be fair as a
mathematics teacher
I think obviously I'm somewhat biased
but I think there are few syllabuses few
curriculum areas that are as detailed
and as prescriptive as the mathematics
syllabus and despite that fact
I think there is enormous space for
autonomy I'll give you a quick example
when I teach my students about the
physical concepts that are part of
mathematics things like motion
displacement velocity acceleration I am
required I am mandated to teach this
particular equation I need to teach this
method for solving a problem yes those
very specific and very you know
regimented in some ways however what is
the way that I'm going to engage my
students to help them understand those
concepts am I going to show them all of
the equations on the board lay down all
the theory and then show them a series
of problems they can now see in the real
world to do with astronomy or to do with
vehicles moving around a racetrack well
I do it that way maybe I won't even talk
about theory at all maybe the first
thing I'll do is I'll take my students
out into the playground and we'll throw
tennis balls and basketballs and
different objects around and we will
observe the patterns we'll film it we'll
put it in slow motion and then we'll
watch as these objects trace perfect
mathematical lines through the sky I
could go on and on and on
I really have true autonomy within my
own class context to take those specific
ideas but allow my students to
experience in a way that actually makes
sense to them well you're not liar in
school as a teacher were you doing too
much where you're the overachieving
teacher I wouldn't say so I think one of
the great our hallmarks of the
Australian education system is how
wonderfully stocked we are with very
skilled and passionate and dedicated
teachers and probably what I've been
able to do has become a little more
visible just because of the the use of
the internet and what's accessible now
through YouTube but I'm delighted I get
to go to teacher conferences and meet
other colleagues who are they put me to
shame to be honest so I'm one of many
teachers who are very clear we're going
to continue this conversation stay tuned
to let's talk my guest tonight Eddie
whoo
[Music]
I'm a teacher because I find joy in
seeing children grow opening their eyes
to the world around them and helping
them find that unique place in it I feel
my lessons every day so that no matter
who you are or where you live you can
access the world of mathematics and
learn from it and mathematics
I love teaching it's amazing because
it's woven into every part of our lives
from the algorithms that make modern
technology work to the beautiful spiral
of seeds in a sunflower embracing
mathematics is a way to help us
appreciate and understand the world in a
deeper and richer way than any of us
could ever have imagined welcome back to
let's talk I'm sure I'd couldn't my
guest tonight Eddie woo Australia's
leading mathematics educator and
communicate and you know that video we
saw just now perfect example of the kind
of things that you do I would asked you
about the schools that we left the
conversation just now on schools and you
said Australian schools are a places
where people go teachers who choose that
as a vocation you know inspired to help
their young people but it seems like a
lot of us went through school whether in
Malaysia or elsewhere with a rather
negative view of maths in particular all
fella we're not good enough for it and
we were failing in such is it because of
what the schools are doing that
mathematics is taught in a way that
actually puts young people off Sharada I
think you've really touch on a nerve
there because when a lot of people meet
me and they find out I'm a mathematics
teacher I generally get one of two
responses every now and then I have
someone who says oh that's that's great
I come an engineer I'm an actuary I love
mathematics when I was at school God
happens about one in every 100 times
that I made people the other 99 I do
find people who are very very quick to
say oh I don't just say I hated
mathematics they say I hate mathematics
present tense and as we talk and as we
we converse and I explain what it is
that I think mathematics is if I have
enough time to have a chat with them
we often leave the conversation
realizing that it's
mathematics that they hated it was
actually the way that they learned it
which was which was negative which was
inaccessible and it alien aided them in
fact from a subject which they can
embrace and they realize sometimes much
later than they wanted to that this is
something they missed out on at school
okay let's before we get to the students
I'm just want to know if we could turn
somebody like me around could you and
then I was very inspired by your TED
talk by the way the idea that math is
all around us could you make adults have
left school you know a long time ago
love math again it see it as something
that they could be fascinated by I'd
like to say that I I'll try I mean for
me I think that mathematics is something
which I know from my own journey
something that cannot be appreciated
early on but in fact can be slowly
developed I compared it a little bit to
developing a taste for a certain food
you know when I was little I was a
really fussy eater I caused enormous
problems for my mom I just said I don't
want to eat that I don't want to eat
that today I only eat blue food you know
I was really difficult to work for and
to provide food for but then as I grew
and as I matured own eyes as I
deliberately gave myself opportunities
to try new and different things I was
able to expand my palate and of course
I've benefited from that more diverse
willingness to eat food now with
mathematics I think that the same is
true you know I I made this comparison
to food let me make this comparison to
music most people would say yeah I enjoy
music I enjoy a particular kind of music
but if all you ever experienced was one
style maybe was just classical maybe it
was just pop or maybe it was dubstep
whichever one it was if that was the
only one that people ever heard out in
the world you wouldn't be surprised that
most people actually don't like that
classical music not my thing just for a
very small subset of the population but
if what we can do is actually show the
diversity of musical flavours that are
out there you'll eventually find your
pocket and it's the same with mass if
there's someone who's very interested in
the legal system in justice you know
mathematics is in there you did you
realize I learnt this actually not that
long ago myself
in the judicial system when we determine
okay someone perhaps is guilty we need
to determine what would be the length of
their sentence we have mathematical
algorithms designed to help us be more
just more fair unbiased to help us make
those decisions and be fair and
equitable and create a system that
produces a just society
there's mathematics in the legal system
right and that would be a new invention
right oh I guess you'd rely on the judge
who would have precedent would remember
how sentencing was meted out in the
earlier practice okay let's go back to
the school and what is it the schools
are doing wrong when it comes to math
what is it they're not telling either
the teachers or the students that's
turning this into a rather torturous
experience for young people there's a
few things I could point to you I mean
amidst all the great work that is
happening in many schools we insist on
focusing in many places still on a
process focused view of mathematics what
does this look like I'll say Sharad
we're going to learn the quadratic
formula today okay I want you to
memorize x equals minus b plus or minus
the square root of b i can already see
you starting to glaze okay so I'm going
to give you this formula and I'm going
to expect you to be able to perform put
the numbers in get a number out you
might say why am I doing this I'm gonna
say schrott don't ask me why just do it
that's what matters in the exam you
don't need to tell me why you need to be
able to answer the question and in fact
by doing that sadly we actually
short-circuit our students ability to
develop that that purpose part of
motivation are we surprised that they
are unmotivated when they have no reason
to actually engage with these very
difficult abstract ideas if instead I
said to you you know what all we're
trying to do here is solve problems that
matter financially that matter in terms
of perhaps you love sports and trying to
work out where am I going to hit this
golf swing or where am I gonna kick this
ball I'm trying to solve a problem that
matters to you and I can use this
particular method to do it now you have
a purpose for it that I see is something
that's missing in many schools right
okay but we learnt to count more more
than just using our fingers and toes and
such right Abby
there's a level of abstraction in masses
and is that is that a skill too I mean
if everything is applied in terms of you
know daily activities yeah are you
missing out in some other dimension of
math right so what are the strengths of
mathematics but it ends up being also
two-edged sword there's a danger to it
which I'll explain in a second one of
the strengths of mathematics is that it
applies to a completely broad range of
things you know if you have a look at a
shape like which I was talking about the
quadratic formula before this describes
chase we called parabolas if you look at
a fountain you see the water arcing up
through the air it stops just at the top
and then it comes down it's perfectly
symmetrical shape this is a parabola now
this is not the only place you find
parabolas if there's a comet that's
approaching the Sun and it whips around
and we just see it from Earth for a
little while and then it turns around
and off heads back into space again
surprise prize this same shape is traced
out and I could go on and on and on the
whole point of abstraction saying
instead of a fountain or instead of a
comet instead I say x-squared and I
leave you all these symbols which don't
necessarily have a specific meaning the
point is to say these could be anything
they might not be these objects they
might be money they might be electrical
signals but the problem is sometimes we
forget to actually connect it to a
context and we must do that so our
students appreciate what's the meaning
of all this why do we do it one of the
things that you do say you know speech
in TEDx is that you go that in doing
math you're involved in a creative
process something that I don't think
people are sociated math how is it
creative what I want to say to do here
is to broaden what our sense of
creativity is in mathematics I'll give
you an example we want to prove that
things are true it's really important to
us that we can use logic and we can
reuse reasoning and we can actually come
to a point where we convince ourselves
not only is this maybe true I can be
rock-solid true
I can send human beings into space and
be so confident mathematically that they
are going to go in exactly the
trajectory to land on this moon and then
come back safely
I'll bank on it I'll bank these people's
lives on it and so when we're reasoning
when we're arguing mathematically there
may be one destination
maybe one result we want to prove or one
answer we get to but there are so many
different paths to get there in fact
that's how we gain certainty in
mathematics we prove things through a
variety of different means and it takes
creativity to think of those different
means and that's not to mention when we
think about things like the arts I
mentioned music before visual arts is
intensely mathematical all of the the
patterns and symmetry all of those have
mathematical foundations woven
underneath them
I think Carnatic music in southern India
is also very mathematical you talked
about Islamic arts as well in your
presentation as being very mathematical
well hold that thought we'll come right
back with Eddie wolf in a short time
stay tuned
[Music]
welcome back to let's talk I'm
shortcutting with me Eddie whoo he's
Australia's leading mathematics educator
communicator YouTube I don't know
there's anybody bigger on YouTube in
math than you in Australia you have some
[Music]
you don't keep writing you know keep
okay what you do make an argument for is
a new way of thinking about mathematics
you call it the sense mathematical
thinking is a sense explain that to me
so I don't mean this in a literal sense
it's a metaphor for me but it's an
incredibly powerful metaphor now the
reason why I like to describe it in this
way is because there's a very
traditional view of what mathematical
skill is and that's what educators often
called a fixed mindset and the fixed
mindset is you know what some people are
just born with matter-of-fact
mathematical brains and some people
don't and for the rest of it for the
normal people who don't we just sort of
throw our hands up and we're helpless
sorry it's just not something I can do
now there are clear problems with that
there's we once upon a time could plead
ignorance about what was happening
physiologically in the brain and we
could we could pretend yeah that there
is such a thing as a Matt's brain it's
it's actually different in its structure
but now we know better we have
functional magnetic resonance imaging
machines that these fMRI look inside the
brain as people are engaged in
mathematics there's no structural
difference between people who are great
at maths and people who are not now in
opposition to the idea of fixed mindset
there's a sort of other end of the
extreme it's sort of a fluid mindset
where it's almost like the brain is
completely plastic I can change it to be
whatever I want anyone can be on Stein
anyone can be Rach matanov and can do
whatever they want with their brain
almost like a Disney movie
if Sharada you'll only believe now those
are mainstream very restrained and so
what is it right now what is that taking
that extreme taking YouTube now that
extreme I think it ends up while it has
some great strengths because what it
does say is you know what as opposed to
this fixed idea you can develop this
mathematical skill and I think that is
demonstrably true if you have a child
and you you help them and you provide
support and you
so a system to regularly practice
surprise surprise they develop
mathematical skill that they didn't have
before so there is evidence to support
that idea as a whole but the problem is
you put this burden you place this
impossible expectation on students who
perhaps may have a natural flair and an
enjoyment in other areas and you say no
no but I expect you to be this and so
the reason why I love the idea the
metaphor of mathematics is a sense is
because it marries up these two ideas in
a way that I hope does justice to what
we are as human beings number one it's
true there are some parts of us where
there's a fixed idea of I have great
senses when it comes to tastes and I
have terrible senses when it comes to
eyes like it looks like you share with
me Sharad I actually only knowledge I
have a short-sighted eye in a long
sighted eye it's very very confusing but
while I have fixed limitations physical
limitations on my vision that doesn't
mean I can't actually refine my senses
and you know I talked about my taste
buds before those taste buds have
changed over time I have friends who
over many many years have become you
know real wine connoisseurs they go on
tours they drink this one and this one
and this one and they say wow this one's
this one's different this is nice and
fruity this one's very dry and I say how
can a wine be dry it's wet isn't it this
is something I clearly have not
cultivated myself but they have I have
some friends who are musical and they
would listen to a note playing on an
instrument they'll say that's a that's a
c-sharp I said how did you know that
they said we've learned to develop
perfect pitch now the senses may be
rigid in physical realities that some
people are better than others but they
can be sharp and they can be refined and
that's why I think mathematics is
somewhere in the middle
neither fixed nor completely fluid but
like a sense that allows us to perceive
the world and what we can actually grow
okay well some people might say well
actually what math is is a skill right
it's about counting and you know
counting fast and I remember in school
being taught you know having to memorize
the times table right so you'd have to
memorize it
five because I always got it wrong and
the thing is is it a skill I mean it
should we think of it as a skill it's
necessary in later life and you know
applied to other fields and so on and so
forth I think that mathematics is a
skill the same way that journalism is
spelling clearly it helps to be an
accurate speller if you want to be an
effective and respected journalist like
you are but that's clearly one narrow
part of the broader skill set that we
would say journalism is we want us to is
to be good at arithmetic we want them to
be able to you know manipulate algebra
without thinking too hard about it
because it comes naturally to them
because it's they're fluent in it like a
language but that's just one small part
of mathematical knowledge and growth I
mean we want students also to be able to
communicate their thinking to to reason
to be able to problem-solve and meet a
problem they've never encountered before
but still solve it and that's more than
just a skill okay so you talk about
patterns relationships and logical
connections as that part of that skill
set right all that sense what is it
about patterns that is mathematical so
we live in a patterned universe I mean
one of the things that I am is obsessed
with words and where they come from and
I didn't notice until recently but but
cosmos
you know synonym we when we say the
universe is the cosmos but actually
cosmos means orderly and patent and the
opposite of cosmos is chaos which is
just disorderly and random now when we
live in a universe that is patterned in
which you know even when there are not
patents the human beings I've been
looking out at the night sky and all
these stars and we see constellations
but every culture in the world sees
different constellations to the rest
because we find different patterns in
this sea of basically randomness and we
are wired to see patterns and whether
they are natural ones when we look out
at a rainbow when we say rainbows
they're perfectly round why there's a
pattern there that's from the natural
world and there are patterns we create
I've really enjoyed today I actually got
to go up to the the Petronas Towers I
got right up onto the observation deck
and just marveling at the Geo
a tree of this city clearly the
architecture in the design is is hugely
mathematical and so whether it's the
natural world or the created world the
constructed world mathematics is
everywhere it's always hard to avoid ok
that this bring us back to the the
conversation we were having earlier
about your background in literature and
history night you know it seems that
this there is a there's a hierarchy of
knowledge at least the minds of people
and that math occupies part of the
pinnacle it's close to the pinnacle of
that and something like history for some
people are unimportant as a teacher from
a pedagogical point of view do you think
that's mistaken I mean how do we how do
we locate these different knowledge and
skill sets you know against each other I
think coming back to that metaphor
senses actually will be really helpful
here because we have the five classical
senses of seeing hearing smelling
tasting and touchy and we know that
these all are in fact complimentary I
don't think anyone would say even though
of course we are very much visual
creatures and huge parts of the brain
are devoted just to see if seeing was
the only sense we had if we prize that
among over and against every other sense
what what a narrow and and you know
impoverished view and experience of the
world we would have and so for me I
think it's really about having a rich
view and experience a diverse experience
of the world and there are things that
we cannot prove mathematically we can
only know them for example personally we
can only know them through culture and
so mathematics is a very powerful set of
tools but it has to be used in concert
in a complementary fashion with the
other field so would you say that the
education system that says let's
emphasize STEM education science
technology engineering mathematics is
mistaken Sir Ken Robinson is a wonderful
voice for educators and I think one of
the things which he points out very
clearly is how when we you know put an
emphasis on for example those particular
disciplines that allow us to solve
practical problems out in the world
if we do that at the expense of some of
our creative pursuits then in fact we
shortchange ourselves you know if we
want to as we're saying before solve the
problems out in the world today we
actually need all of those creative
skills those who do not learn history I
do to repeat it in no matter how fancy
our formulas may be if we do not become
wise to what we have what we've done
before and what has gone wrong before
then we are looking forward to
recreating that that history whether it
was good or bad so I think it is a
mistake to say one area of knowledge is
more important than all of the rest I
think it's that unity that's much more
importantly to be valued ok thank you
very much I'm speaking to Eddy wool
Australia's leading mathematics educated
communicator we'll be back
stay tuned
[Music]
welcome back to let's talk I'm sure I'd
cut in with me Eddie whoo he's from
Australia with Malaysian roots and he's
Australia's leading mathematics educator
he's a recipient of many awards he won
Austria's local hero award at the
Australian of the Year awards that was
in January last year and then in March
he was named as a top 10 finalists in
the global teacher prize all accolades
for a very young man who's done
extraordinary things at least in the
view of matha you're a teacher you're a
teacher and I remember your cherrybrook
but a beautiful name for a school
cherrybrook teachers and instructors
about teachers in Australia our teachers
in Australia empowered to be
stakeholders in discussions about
education policy do they are their
feedback mechanisms how involved are
teachers in shaping what happens in
schools teachers in Australia have this
great opportunity to always provide
their voice in all of our for example
syllabus design processes we always have
a consultation period where every
teacher gets the same weight as an
organization that's really large they
can put in their submission put lots of
time and thought and effort into that
and it goes into the official record and
it gets produced in the minister or a
report we still have a long way to go
though when where teachers can actually
become decision-makers who are at the
table and having I think the kind of
voice that they need to really shift and
guide what's happening in the classroom
because they are eminently qualified to
do that being the people doing the work
themselves so they don't have autonomy I
you say with regard to the school the
curriculum that's where they lack
they're not empowered is that what you
say so it's it's a complicated picture I
think it's I want to resist you know the
the oversimplification of saying look
they just have no power because that's
not true
but at the same time there's a long way
to go still and let me illustrate this I
was talking about the the syllabus
consultation period that happens very
recently we had new syllabuses
introduced in
mathematics English science and history
for fun five inform six students and so
the whole curriculum from for some areas
in the first time in decades was really
radically changed as shifted now many
changes were made many changes were
suggested and then teachers had had
months to have a look at that to
diagnose it's a dissect it and say these
are things which we think are great
these are changes which we think clearly
need a bit more thought and there were
real changes made in response to those
teachers suggestions so no one can say
Oh teachers have no opportunity teachers
a sign they have no opportunity to have
an influence on what they are teaching
but at the same time there are lots of
decisions that are made which are not to
do with what is best for students which
sometimes there are lots of lots of
stakeholders in this decision making
process education is something that
everyone cares about and often teachers
despite being the ones who are going to
implement the curriculum and teach them
to students don't get the opportunity to
say what they need to say what's the
most powerful voice in education in
Australia is it the parent of the
parents the ones who are determining
things are there politicians who have
taken those positions it's a really
interesting and more dynamic lines
landscape is what I would say I mean you
mentioned parents you mentioned
politicians in addition to those I would
add universities there's an incredible
voice from the tertiary sector which has
a lot to say about what kinds of
students we want exiting our secondary
schools and that's a very fair call to
make I mean one of the things that we
were really worried about was students
who are coming out of school and they
were not prepared for engineering
courses which required really
significant advanced levels of
mathematics and so right at least so
they had a voice at the table and then
of course we also have industry industry
wants to make sure they're people who
have the right skills to enumerate who
can make decisions and also work
together with other people
okay you know what about the the
question of you know research is there
much research happening so that when you
formulate a policy are you looking at
the curriculum are you looking at you
know what actually is transforming the
the the learning experience for the
young person or transforming outcomes is
there much research and who's doing it
in Australia and this is a growing field
I think that the mathematical education
research group in Australia Mugur as we
are oh it's actually all that matter
what its actual name is it has been
meaning for decades and it is a very
powerful force however at the same time
I hasten to say we are overshadowed by
places like the US and the UK which
obviously have advantages of scale but
even without when we would take that
factor out of the equation pardon the
pun they are doing a lot more work in
terms of researching innovative
practices looking at evidence based so
it is this assessment style actually
helping our students learn we know we
can get really good data out of it but
does it help students have a more
positive experience in the classroom
that actually equips them in the
workforce those questions are ones which
we are struggling to answer in places
like Australia and it's not enough to
look at overseas context if there's one
thing I've learned about looking at
educational systems around the world
whether it's Dubai or Uganda or here in
Malaysia it's that no matter which great
system you look at Finland Shanghai
Singapore etc you cannot simply take
their ideas and their research and drop
them into your own context why not
differences ok cultural differences so
when it goes to mass education we had a
controversy in this country some years
ago when the government tried to push
the learning not a math but of the
English and they decided that it was
going to be the the the the vehicle for
that would be science and math so there
was pushback because they said and
people who were against this said in
fact math is best learnt in the mother
tongue now is that the kind of
conversation you have in Austria I mean
do you add those cultural issues really
that significant in the way teach kids
learn something like math it seems to be
about symbols kind of beyond languages
it's a language of its own when my
favorite quotes is from I the scientist
and mathematician and physicist Galileo
Galilei he said mathematics is the
language with which God has written the
universe and I think that that is true
it is
in some ways Universal and beyond in
fact I'm one of the things that's come
out of the videos that I've put on
YouTube which I've been delightfully
surprised by is that even though I teach
the Australian Curriculum and I teach it
in an eminently Australian accent in
fact only eight percent of my viewers
are from Australia and everyone else is
around the world and that speaks to the
universality of mathematics but coming
to the question of culture I mean for me
I mean culture in a very broad sense you
asked before about the idea of you know
what language do we deliver mathematics
in in Australia that specific question
is not being asked but that's because
and this is again this is what I mean by
cultural difference if we look at a
place like Australia and compare it to
say Finland Finland of course because of
its results in global assessments like
Pisa and Tim's has gained rightfully a
lot of attention but a lot of people
don't notice the fact that Finland is a
trilingual country almost every person
speaks through language is not that
dissimilar to here but for different
reasons Europe of course is its own
environment Australia by contrast is
essentially a single language system now
that's actually really important the
ability to be fluent in multiple
languages is a huge asset when it comes
to learning another language like
mathematics so which language do we
offer it in I think is less an important
question down what's the environment of
a student's mind what's the landscape in
there that fits them better or poorer
for learning the language of mathematics
okay I have a really big question for
you but we're running out time gonna
come back to the next section I want to
get your sense or what ought to change
if you I made you if I had a magic wand
I made you the Minister of Education
what would you do and that's coming up
in the next section stay tuned to let's
talk
[Music]
welcome back to let's talk I'm short
cuttin with me Eddie whoo Oh stress
leading mathematics educated
communicator and if I was if I woke up
tomorrow as prime minister of the
country
I would make him the minister of
education and and I would but I would
audition you first and I would say to
you what would you do for math education
in this country or any country let's
assume it's a country a nameless country
what would you do
I'm gonna throw two big ideas at you and
they are radical but in an environment
like today where we have so many
students coming out of our mathematics
classrooms vehemently disliking the
subject I think that calls for radical
change so if my first suggestion would
be I really think assessment needs to
undergo a transformation to the exam
system correct in fact I think the whole
idea of exams while they do have value I
don't want to get rid of exams but if
they are the only way that our students
experience have their have their
knowledge and have their skill measured
I think in fact we are giving them a we
are getting a very false representation
of their mathematical skill and time and
time again and if there are any teachers
watching tonight I think they would this
would resonate with them I sometimes
have to write a report comment that
sounds a little bit like sherrod is an
effective mathematician in class but
this result does not reflect his true
ability because there sit an exam
it's under it's under time pressure it's
all about memory and suddenly students
are very stressed their fight-or-flight
response kicks in and actually that has
been demonstrably shown in research to
really diminish their mathematical
ability under pressure and we know many
of the problems that we want to solve
today that require mathematics no one's
got a three hour timer on you no one is
saying you're not allowed to consult any
kind of textbook law you can't look at
the internet you need to have every
single of those formulas in your brain
that is a completely contrasted so in
addition to exams which
I'm very helpful I want to have a
diverse range of assessments that allow
students to actually show how well they
can communicate mathematically sure how
well they could actually work alongside
others and devise a solution to a
problem they have never ever encountered
before so number one I want to change
the way we assess number two I think the
way that teachers in the classroom need
to relate to their students particularly
in mathematics it really is is in law
made for a fundamental change my math
teacher was at forum one was very strict
and all I remember was that that she was
very strict unfortunate I don't know
being strict and teaching math come
together I hope they don't I really
really hope that the main memory my
students have is not about about
strictness or anything like that and
that memory I think is telling okay so
what would you do for the teacher and in
that classroom situation what is it that
you would want so I mean you comment it
you know it's not just about Malaysia or
Australia or a broader context I think
that's something that is true in every
culture around the world is that
teaching is something which happens by
way of relationship it's by way of
rapport if I don't have a good solid
connection with a student if I don't
know what matters to them what makes
them tick if they don't know a bit about
me and my personality is it's actually
very difficult for genuine learning to
happen I might be able to convey fact
into your brain I may be able to show
you a skill and you can mechanically
follow it but real learning learning
that will stay with you for the rest of
your life that is very difficult to
create without a strong personal
relationship so what I want teachers to
be able to have and that they need to be
provide with the support to do this it's
not their fault now they are very busy
distracted time poor professionals and
so developing this new skill is often
the last thing on their mind
but we need to develop the idea of
communication within the classroom
listening skills and questioning skills
I mean we spend a lot of time on
developing technology and I think that's
great
central to the innovative way to teach
mathematics but if you took every
computer out of my classroom every
scientific calculator out of my
classroom in entire school and instead
you taught those teachers to be really
effective and
sigh SIV questioners this is as ancient
as Socrates but that skill that really
helps to engender deep understand and
that does not happen in teacher training
it doesn't happen nearly enough I think
we get a taste of it you know that our
sense of Educational Psychology for me
was six months out of four years in my
degree and I I got a sense of what it
was about but I had very little
opportunity to actually hone that skill
that all happened when I was in the
classroom and for some teachers they do
not have the support particularly if
they're in a rural or remote area to be
able to develop that skill and have good
role models they need that that's
support underneath them to
professionally develop okay so we have
exams we want to get rid of them or we
want to diversify exactly that's okay
and and then we have teachers we want to
empower them to be the best kind of
teacher to deliver the subject what else
would you do okay we're gonna serve
education remember your your time's
running out then you know and your jobs
on the line okay oh I'll go for the
biggest one last really what's going to
change the way that education works not
just in Malaysia or Australia but around
the world isn't the status and regard of
teachers has to be completely flipped on
its head I mean you stay you stay -
right at the beginning of the show that
teaching is a profession that is highly
denigrated around the world and this is
tragic I mean in a country that offers
compulsory education for which so many
students go through school I think
that's a wonderful thing I think
education is a human right but an
unfortunate side effect is that many
people feel like I went to school I know
how to be a teacher I have it I'm an
expert at this because I was there and I
had my own experience now part of that
is true but a part of that is gravely
mistaken
educational professionals need to be
held in high regard and of course I
would say that as a teacher but when we
don't do that when we have a society in
which who do we you know bring into the
teaching profession people who struggled
and couldn't accomplish in other areas
so they came to this as a as a matter of
second or third or last resort
then we cannot be surprised by that lack
of investment in turn in the next
generation that we as a society don't
pay for that we don't want to have those
consequences of
teachers who aren't supported who aren't
passionate and dedicated and and
academically capable we don't want to
face the consequences of lacking those
people in their profession so if we want
to change that we need to change the
status and regard of teachers okay I'm
not sure if it's entirely in the power
of governments to do that because this
is about society isn't it trend and also
what societies measure success if it's
the Paycheck at the end of the month
teachers not being paid very well then
of course society tends to valid them
less but you know things have changed my
mother was a teacher she taught English
and and literature and you know I'm very
glad that she did it's made me a better
person for it though there are many
minutes so we have Eddie I do want to
ask you this and there's a question
about teaching as well you know you have
a class and you have a wonderfully you
know exciting time and experience with
them and the kids move on as a teacher
where is the possibility for personal
growth
what is it does it what does it mean for
a teacher to grow in that profession so
that it's not repetitive it's not just
yeah new faces same old curriculum out a
related story to Sherrod that I think
perfectly captures how positive we can
be about this particular question you
asked when I started my teaching career
I think it was the first week I came
through five days of teaching and I was
exhausted I every day I got home at you
know 5:00 p.m. and I just went I just
hit the bed and I sort of got up in a
fog at 11:00 at night and I thought what
day is it you know I was exhausted my
met a friend on the weekend and he said
to me hey how's your first week of work
and I said I am exhausted but I'm so
satisfied and delighted by the
opportunity I have to make a difference
in the lives of young people and this
friend of mine this is years ago now he
looked at me straight in the eye and
said I give you six weeks six weeks and
then I think you're going to be my
grizzled old tired cynical teacher and
you're going to say full-time work is
terrible now Here I am more than eleven
years later and every day I feel like I
discover new things new reasons new ways
to grow into this profession and new
things that surprise and delight me now
how do we
do this I think there's at least two big
ways number one when we teach when we
teach an old concept only mathematics is
an ancient art but we can constantly
teach it in new ways I mean one of the
things that I've fallen into is that by
videoing my lessons and putting them
online when I come back to teach a
concept that I've taught before I have a
real motivation to say I want another
way to teach this I want to do like a
standard comment kind of the same joke
say that's exactly right it's kind of
like they'll say to me you've done this
before I've watched that video I want I
want a new experience and I also myself
do not want to become bored mathematics
is a rich subject you can look at it
from so many different angles I like to
compare mathematics topics to diamonds
every time you look at a different
perspective you get a whole new spectrum
of colors if you're willing to change
your pistol right so that's your
personal curiosity about the subject
that you're delivering to the kids final
minutes that we have what will be the
next thing that you say to teachers the
next thing is to continue growing in
your journey as an educator you're one
of the things that I've been
delightfully surprised by is how much
joy and satisfaction I've gained from
not working directly with children but
being able to support other teachers in
their work with children and realizing I
could have a broader impact I'm now old
enough when I look at some of the young
teachers who are coming into the
profession I think hold on I'm old
enough to be your teacher you guys are
just kids I'm now already the next
generation and so I have a
responsibility to share the great
lessons and mentor ships that were given
to me and to pass that on and and that's
a way to continue developing and growing
and rising through this education
profession there are so many
opportunities for growth okay wonderful
and because you have a book it's wus a
wonderful world of math excuse the
alliteration but you know I would ask
you is there a movie deal coming up look
at a government tree perhaps potentially
there may be a Netflix original series
is Netflix paying attention maybe there
is a TV series that we produced on
children's TV in Australia that is all
about developing an understanding of
financial literacy using mathematical
skills in a concrete context I don't
think Hollywood's buying yet but who
knows who knows thank you so much Eddie
whoo Eddie whoo
who was named top 10 finalists in the
global teacher prize also the recipient
of Australia's the local hero award at
the Australian of the Year awards a man
committed to communicating the joys and
the wonders of mathematics this has been
let's talk I'm sure it couldn only an
astral warning
[Music]
you